from the white house it was an
announcement designed to surprise
to make a president facing a tough
election look like the broker
the deal maker and it does because on
the face of it the abraham accord is a
rabbit
out of the hat a significant moment in
the story of the middle east peace
process
just a few moments ago i hosted a very
special call with two friends
prime minister benjamin netanyahu of
israel
and crown prince mohammed bin zaid
of the united arab emirates where they
agreed to finalize a historical peace
agreement
everybody said this would be impossible
in israel it's a win too for prime
minister netanyahu
this is the greatest advancements toward
peace between israel and the arab world
in the last 26 years and it marks the
third formal peace between
israel and an arab nation the suggestion
is he will now suspend plans to annex
parts of the palestinian west bank
but in return he's got a deal with the
uae and a strengthened axis against
common arab-israeli enemy
iran it is more than a quarter of a
century since an arab country created
diplomatic ties with israel
it was bill clinton who bought king
hussein of jordan together with yitzhak
rabin of israel
the only other arab nation with
diplomatic ties with the jewish state
is egypt that deal signed back in 1979.
the foreign minister of the third arab
country now to make this huge diplomatic
shift
spoke to sky news this is a win-win deal
it's a win-win deal for peace
in the region and it brings actually
a ray of hope in a very difficult time
in our region
not known really for good times anyway
in jerusalem there is now the prospect
of gulf arab tourists wandering the old
city
visiting the al-aqsa mosque for the
first time for commerce for tourism for
aviation for geopolitics this is
certainly a crucial juncture
in the long road to middle east peace
but on the other side of israel's
security wall in the west bank there is
a deep sense of betrayal
until now any arab-israeli diplomatic
deal was largely dependent on the
emergence of a palestinian state
and yet these people are no closer to
having that state they remain occupied
replying on twitter to the abu dhabi
crown prince's announcement of the deal
top palestinian diplomat hanan ashwari
wrote
may you never experience the agony of
having your country stolen
may you never feel the pain of living in
captivity under occupation
may you never witness the demolition of
your home or murder of your loved ones
she concluded may you never be sold out
by your friends
the geopolitical reality though now
seems to be that trade commerce
and a strengthened axis against iran now
trumps the palestinian cause
the question now is how many other arab
nations will follow
mark stone sky news in jerusalem